ah
bonjour je suis vraiment très content de
vous voir
vous avez remarqué comme je suis beau et
propre aujourd'hui
nous allons passer une journée
formidable
surtout à cause de la surprise que j'ai
préparé oui je vais vous le dire mais
non par les paraît c'est un concours de
chant ouais voilà le facteur jour je lui
ai justement demandé de venir pour
savoir s'ils pourront participer au
concours
bonjour casimiro martin et tu m'as l'air
bien gai aujourd'hui paraît et je suis
dans une forme étonnante pour beau mais
ça fait plaisir à voir ça pour sûr bon
alors dis-moi pourquoi tu m'as fait
venir à je voudrais savoir si vous
pouvez chanter ooh poursuivre je crois
même casimir que j'ai un assez joli brin
de voix
pourriez me faire entendre quelque chose
euros pour sur
la pelouse
fabien c'est une règle très bien pu
choquer j'en connais un autre os des
repas bon temps
jet tours reprend plus
d'accord ça suffit merci oui ça n'a pas
l'air de beaucoup de plaire si si si si
beaucoup aussi non mais je voulais juste
entendre quelques secondes abobo
alors si tu n'as plus besoin de moi je
vais continuer ma tournée c'est ça bien
pour voir casimiro revoir
je suis le pas selon la la la la la
bien que je n'aie pas d'oreille il ya
certains jours où elles me font très mal
oh non je ne pouvais vraiment pas le
prendre pour le concours qui n'est pas
là monsieur disnat robot casimir je
t'adresse mes salutations distinguées
jean vous remercie alors que t'arrive t
je voudrais savoir si vous savez chanter
quelle question tu sais bien que les
gens de ma qualité connaît dès leur
naissance la pratique de tous les arts
et quand un pouce
alors sanata plus oui oui oui oui je
vois l'entousiasme ne te rends nu et
c'est normal et je dois constater que
cela fait plaisir de voir qu'une belle
voix comme la mienne peut toucher le
coeur de naître aussi peu raffiné que le
tien
il a la chance que je n'ai pas de temps
à perdre sinon je lui montrerai comment
un être aussi peu raffiné que moi comme
je lui montrerai à la boxe a
alors bloqué c'est mieux qu'attendu de
moi et bien batum a fait venir pour
l'otan de quelques notes de ma voix
ah oui voilà ça y est je me souviens oui
le facteur m à apprendre à chanter oui
et il aimerait faire un duo avec vous
allez où est il ce brave emile pavin qui
vient juste de partir pareil bon je le
rattrape et merci casimir
vraiment
voilà julie heureusement salut bonjour
julie on peut vraiment très très belle
tiens vu j'ai mis la robe que tu
préférant oui ça me plaît je suis très
content la publicité
alors quoi explique moi le mystère
pourquoi nous a tous demandé de mettre
nos plus beaux habits ah oui mais
attends j'aimerais d'abord que françois
soit la havane le voilà justement rien
bonjour casimir bon je lis chemise ah
oui était de remarquer c'est ma plus
belle et je deviens tu as un spa un
camélia pas fautif et bien casimir
explique moi ce qui se passe or n'ont
jusqu'ici j'ai rencontré personne on
dirait que tous les enfants ont disparu
de l'île mais c'est vrai regardez jardin
ouais mais alors il n'y a pas un seul
enfant et bien moi ça ne m'étonne pas du
tout c'est une surprise c'est une
surprise à gazinet qu'est-ce que ça ex
détenus quelle est cette surprise encore
un petit instant
bon allez voilà ça y est c'est l'homme a
alors vous voyez le grand rideau qui
hélas oui oui je l'avais pas remarqué eh
bien tous les enfants sont assis devant
les attentes
et qu'est ce qu'ils attendent fort mais
le début du grand concours de chant un
concours de chant et c'est fantastique
mais dis moi quel jour être les
concurrents et bien il y a julie et
françois noah nous un galant nos
collections
mesdames mesdemoiselles et messieurs le
grand concours de chant va commencer
le premier concurrent s'appelle françois
les récits vas-y vas-y aller
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
créée savent c'est ce que je voudrais
l'un si vraiment petit outre m
j'aimerais me connaît m les fourmis les
sourires ont des vies extraordinaires
je
voudrait
vous plaît
on explique ses mystères je voudrais
être très savants que d'être le secret
des choses y at-il vraiment quelque part
des éléphants roses quelqu'un a t'il
deviner ce qu'on trouve au delà des
étoiles il voit ton parfois des lions d
s'ils gagnent les moyens les corbeaux et
les marches tout près
les cadres d'intel
[Musique]
le haut
là
d'un coup d'oeil les dauphins l'est
parce qu'ils sont de vrais mammifères
son
c'est
talons des poissons dans la mer je
voudrais être très sale en connaître le
secret des choses y at-il vraiment
quelque part des éléphants russe
quelques un es tu devines est ce qu'on
trouve au delà des épaules il voit trop
parfois des lions des hommes ou des
cigales
créé
c'est ce que je voudrais
en petit train g
[Musique]
oui
à
[Applaudissements]
mesdames mesdemoiselles et messieurs la
deuxième concurrent de notre concours de
chanson sera mademoiselle julie
[Musique]
m
avec beaucoup de couleurs
avec beaucoup de tout ça
vous rêvez
elle ou deux
non
gigabit et les garçons
casimir chante à sa chanson
[Musique]
françois
les nouveaux jeux
steam
[Musique]
je l'aimé ou pas si je vais
là je l'aurais mieux peu si j'étais
vraiment
[Musique]
à
amano
dans le kiosque à l'écouté
puis le collier
leur serine titre onfray est grand a
là un papillon passer le temps
assis sur un banc geo
avoue garder butiner les abeilles
mais je ne veux pas si je
je mourrai mieux comme si j'étais sa
main
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
hahaha
bravo julie tu as très bien chanté j'ai
fait une peur terrible c'est très
impressionnant que résonnaient ce n'est
pas fini il faut maintenant attendre les
résultats mesdames mesdemoiselles
messieurs nous allons procéder à
l'élection du gagnant grâce à vos
applaudissements et à ma machine à
mesurer les applaudissements
voilà
le gagnant sera celui qui aura eu les
bravos les plus forts mois casimir je
ferai le feu le juge le premier prix
sera un énorme est délicieux gâteaux à
la crème chantilly
c'est un premier prix formidables
j'adore la crème chantilly
alors attention hein pour la chanson de
françois applaudissements
ou bien machines à mesurer les
applaudissements donne 20 sur 20 robra
bout tu vas gagner certainement
pour le deuxième concurrent julie
applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
écoute julie je crois que tu as gagné
c'est pas possible c'était beaucoup plus
fort pour toi
voici donc les résultats du concours
font quoi et julie sont deuxièmes
ex-aequo deuxième elle a dû se tromper
premiers gagnants du concours
casimir
pas quelques jours la ville a même pas
chanter
gaz inerte yatela comment se fait-il que
du soin gagnant tu ne m'aimes pas
chanter c'est par souci d' injustice à
de justice où nous voudrions avoir une
petite explication il est normal que ce
soit le premier qui mange le gâteau
n'est ce pas c'est vrai on peut rien
dire sauf bon alors je suis obligé
d'être le gagnant parce que j'ai déjà à
manger le gâteau
habitude de chansons et un peu
d'imagination
je me sens maintenant repris
[Musique]
tranquillement
ne soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le monde qui fait rire
quel amour couleur orange
[Musique]
aussi toute confiance
si l'on manie maladroit
que moi
je sais jouer de la musique
je suis né
martinique
la grâce au sang chaud amis c'est qu'on
voit c'est mon droit
a vécu deux chansons
un peu d'imagination
mais nous dans notre it is au pays du
bonheur tranquille
[Musique]
c'est leur rencontre et ne soyez pas
terrorisé
je suis le monstre qui fait rire
[Musique]
appel
j'ai une
machine est une idée fantastique
je mange
gloubi boulga des jeunes en
somalie la campagne
j'ai vu ma ni dans mon camion
cinéma4 toi c'est mon droit
hongrois
a vécu tous champions
[Musique]
magie nas
mais nous dans notre île
au pays du bonheur
tant pis
il pouvait raconter
ne soyez pas terroriste
je suis le bon sens qui fait rire
[Musique]
casimir
[Applaudissements]